Ben is with us in Naples Italy hey Ben
what's up hi Dave I appreciated
appreciate you taking my call
sure know what are you doing in Italy
I work as a DoD civilian ok here in
Naples so cool how kind of help so so
I'm gonna disabled veteran and I was
I'm currently debt free only for my
mortgage and then I'm getting I was
getting treatment for my
service-connected condition on base and
I started getting bills from the
Department of Treasury and so I started
forwarding forwarding those bills over
to the VA and if you're familiar with
the VA everything's a process and in the
meantime the Department of Treasury sent
my bills over to collection and they
dropped my 820 credit score to 600 and
it really hurts because I was in the
process of refinancing my home and I'm
wondering what can I do well you don't
have a lot of pool because you're
dealing with a huge animal called the
government as you figured out and
obviously their incompetence and slow
processes have cost you your credit
score because the bottom line is you owe
the money according to the Treasury
Department
the via they didn't build the VA they
build you and when you didn't pay it and
they've dinged your credit score and
unless you can talk them into undoing
that which I would say is about a zero
chance but you always try go guys you
report this to the credit bureau and I'm
a disabled vet and for goodness sakes
here the VA was supposed to be paying
this and they haven't paid it it's not
my fault you guys got to give me some
help here I need you to go to the credit
bureau and reverse that negative entry
you've made good luck with that but
that's really what should happen isn't
it yeah
but I don't have a lot of optimism to
you I I don't I don't then it's caused
me a severe depression and you know I
really don't know how to deal with this
okay well let's stop right there the
depression I getting depressed over your
credit score being down that was your
choice it didn't cause them you just
decided this was a bigger deal than it
is I mean your credit scores down it's a
bad thing but it's not that dadgum into
the world so what you know we don't you
don't need to worry you don't need to
worship at the altar of the great FICO
he is not your provider you know my
credit score is a zero I'm not depressed
you see what I'm saying I intentionally
did that and so what I would do is get
the problem solved and take action on
the problem but I don't know that your
credit score is going to recover unless
you can talk the Department of Treasury
into re-entering the data with the
credit bureau but I I you know if you
can do that I mean you you probably
ought to be in sales but I would not
accept it as a life altering situation
it's not I mean there's nothing to be
depressed about it's just a stupid
credit score and so I mean whoopee you
didn't refinance your house where's your
house in the states yeah it's in San
Diego now just sell it I mean if you if
you can't refinance it you can't afford
it it doesn't work the way it is just
sell it I mean there's all kinds of
stuff you can do short of being
depressed it's just money man and it's
just it's just it's just a FICO score
for God's sakes it doesn't mean that
much except it's got a block on
something you were trying to do and and
the aggravating part is you didn't
deserve it
what you deserved would be honored for
your service and your you know your
government your country to take care of
you but the VA and the Treasury
Department have not ever been known for
that
so it's oxymoronic to me that the
Veterans Administration was formed to
take care of veterans and doesn't do it
on a very seldom very seldomly people at
the VA actually take care of our
veterans you're just aggravating
so but you know here we go so I'm sorry
sir I wish I could tell you something
else but only thing I can't tell you is
to keep it in perspective it's just a
FICO score you know sell the house it's
not that big a deal and get you into the
house and I'd rather you didn't have a
credit score because you quit borrowing
money